what do you think would this man make a
good doctor what about him would you
trust him with your surgery
most people would probably want to get
treated by one rather than the other
and most people are likely to be wrong
about that
when you look at the sun you sometimes
see it clearly but sometimes you'll see
it shining way bigger than its actual
shape that circle of light that makes it
look bigger is called a halo
the halo effect also happens when a
person product or company shines like
the sun
then we don't see them clearly and
associate all sorts of unrelated
qualities to them
the halo effect was first identified in
1907 by the american psychologist
frederick wells and was then studied by
the psychologist edward thorndike who
asked flight commanders to evaluate
their officers in various distinct
aspects such as physical appearance
intelligence and leadership
examining the results thorndike found
that the officers that got high scores
for their physical qualities also got
rated high on intelligence and
leadership skills a correlation that
seemed wrong
it appears that the commanders were
unable to evaluate specific traits
independently of others
they thought of their officers in broad
terms either good or bad and allowed
this general feeling to influence the
specific qualities they attributed to
them
some officers profited from their halo
others were put at a disadvantage by
what is called the horn effect
the halo effect also explains why some
teachers give better looking students
higher grades
one study looked at the grades of
4500 pupils who were sorted by
volunteers into three groups below
average average and above average
looking
did the better looking people get better
grades
the researchers then compared students
grades between classes taken in
traditional classrooms with those taken
online where there was little to no
face-to-face interaction
the researchers later found evidence
that students who were rated as good
looking earned significantly lower
grades in online courses compared to
traditional classrooms where they got
help from their halo
since the physical attributes of good
good-looking people seem to naturally
make them also appear intelligent strong
and trustworthy here is one good rule of
thumb
if you have an accident and you have to
choose between two equally qualified
doctors ignore their halo and choose the
less handsome one
he might have worked twice as hard to
gain the same reputation and is likely
better at his job
what do you think do you think it is
possible to avoid the halo effect at
work in school or in public life
and what about other credentials that
may signal success
please share your thoughts and ideas in
the comments below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts